how many
times would you estimate that you were
called into school
to meet my teachers uh on
a day that was not actually designated
for meetings between parents and
teachers
there were many incidents some of them
by phone
some of them by report card but the one
thing that was consistent
was that steve is capable of so much
more if he only put some effort into it
that's that that was a mantra and it
used to be the teacher
saying that until the motley crue story
and without
rehashing it i called every hotel in the
yellow pages to meet motley crew i
accomplished
that you took photos of me with the
members of motley crue
and then it turned into a curse for the
rest of my life he said
every time a report card came in every
time i was injured
son of steve if you would just show the
initiative to you know to your
schoolwork to
fill in the blank that you did to meet
motley crew you could accomplish
anything
yeah well you spent a whole sunday
afternoon
calling every hotel in the toronto
telephone book
and it took you until the end of the day
to get the right hotel
so that was initiative yeah and that was
lacking in every other aspect of your
life
right was that was that really the first
time you saw steve like
take any sort of real passion and
initiative for something
uh yeah
he had you know as a kid little league
baseball
i mean there was a lot of stuff when he
put his mind to something
you know he would go out and do it but
that was to me the most impressive
it was uh what grade were you in when
you did that i was in eighth grade and
you went to school the next day and
you're like guess what dudes
i went to school the next day wearing my
girls girls girls uh concert
t-shirt which had like just a big
stripper bent over with her butt and a
thong
and they sent me home from school that
day to change my shirt
really yeah i was i was super proud of
that well the thing i
the thing i remember was that the curve
started
our company had a you know skybox in the
maple leaf gardens
and nobody that the company would want
to go and see the motley crew
so i got the sky box and i got somebody
to smuggle in your recording equipment
but no we did
we we we did it we brought it and we
went now you
i think you gave it to the company
driver and he put it in
ahead of time to the because you
wouldn't have been allowed in the door
of the gardens
with your recording equipment and i came
home as a surprise and i said steve
guess what
i got the skybox at the gardens
you got your recording in there and i
thought i was
super dad i really felt hot [ __ ] and
your immediate reaction was
[ __ ] dad that's lame who wants to watch
the crew in a sky box
yeah dude watching motley crue like
behind a plate glass window
sucks and then i said then i said
fine you get better seats on your
initiative
and i'll take you there and easy to
cancel the box
but if you want better seating than that
you've got to accomplish it
and that's where the initiative piece
came in whoa okay
that coupled with the fact that i saw
the day before the concert that motley
crew was in town and the news was
complaining that these rock stars in our
town
causing trouble and i was like wow
they're already here
can i just tell you how [ __ ] up my new
tour is
it's completely multimedia legitimately
x-rated there's legal waivers all over
the venue because i'm actually worried
about getting sued
and i don't give a [ __ ] man because it's
gnarly
and it's all the stuff i wasn't allowed
to do on jackass
so get to my [ __ ] website stevo.com
and get your tickets man especially with
this movie coming out dude
they're all gonna sell dude so hurry up
while you can get seats